bonsoir François cusé bonsoir bienvenue
en apparté c'est gentil de me recevoir
vous connaissez vous connaissez cette
adresse oui j'ai l' presque les clés en
effit bon je suis très heureuse de vous
revoir ici c'est gentil alors oui
l'heure de la rentrée à sonner hein pour
les jeunes pour les parents pour les
profs aussi on va y venir bien sûr avec
votre film dans un instant euh vous avez
changer la et oui mais c'est beau parce
que moi j'habite dans un coin un peu
comme ça par exemple oui peut-être du
côté des Alpes Maritimes exactement oui
vous en venez vous faites des
allers-retours donc c'est ça oui voilà
c'està dire bah on a tellement la chance
après 50 ans de carrière finalement si
on est encore demandé c'est une telle
chance que on peut puis vous savez on a
tellement de temps libre aussi parce que
plus vous vieillissez moins il y a de
rôles euh bon évidemment on peut
toujours tout acceptter mais disons des
des des rôles où vous êtes motivés pour
pour pour essayer essayer de donner le
meilleur parce que finalement l'âge le
plus employé au cinéma c'est c'est 30 30
40 h que ça soit pour les hommes comme
pour les femmes ilsons peut-être 50 pour
les hommes un peu moins mais enfin bon
les rôles de grand-père ne sont pas
aussi fréquent ça veut dire que ils sont
pas assez fréquents ils sont pas assez
intéressants les deux je dirais les deux
parce que regardez de pher le film de de
Florian Zeller voilà un rôle sublime
mais euh anon hkins voilà alors ça c'est
une chance d'avoir un acteur pareil dans
dans un rôle pareil mais pourtant il y a
pas mal de de de gens de cet âge là qui
vont au cinéma mais peut-être qu'ils ont
envie de voir la jeunesse plutôt que que
leur âge je sais pas on sait rien non ce
qui est bon c'est le théâtre parce que
le théâtre là là vous avez là vous
pouvez jouer tartuf encore à ce â là
mais sur le cinéma il y a une petite
mélancolie de votre part amertume c'est
pas du tout nostalgique de ma part mais
j'attends pas obligatoirement les beaux
rôles ça m'est égal je veux bien avoir
3e 4e rôle ce que je veux c'est les bons
mettant en scène et pour moi un bon mant
en scène c'est alors un grand mettant en
scène c'est un cinéaste qui a du style
et ça ils sont peu fréquent après les
bons mets en scène c'est pas si
compliqué la technique le bon m en scène
pour moi c'est surtout l'humain et là et
ben ça sera réfi aussi c'est-à-dire que
pour être un leader faut faut très
apprécié de son équipe parce que un chef
devant 100 personnes 50 sur le plateau
50 en post-production il faut pour que
tout le monde se surpasse avoir une
admiration une attirance quelque chose
qui fait que vous avez une aura et cette
aura elle ne peut venir que de votre
cœur de votre générosité alors
installez-vous peut-être si vous voulez
au contoir là où vous étiez ou sur le
canapé c'estime Ceto alors je vous en
prie vous pouvez prendre place euh on va
se parler euh bien sûr de ce métier
sérieux un métier sérieux pour être
exact nouveau film de Thomas lilty
actuellement en salle là depuis hier euh
autour de vous le casting est formidable
he quatre étoiles Adel xarcopoulos Louis
Bourgouin Vincent Lacoste William legil
ou encore buouly laners euh vous êtes
Pierre professeur de français un peu le
doyen de la bande au sein d'un collège
de banlieu le film raconte le quotidien
de ses profs passionnés par leur métier
avec aussi leur tour
te le rature leur vie quotidienne le
engagement et puis les
dysfonctionnements bien sûr du système
mais selon moi il n'est jamais maniqué
on va regarder la bande annonce et vous
allez me dire si je me trompe après
d'accord
allez-ce qui passe i qu'estce qui se
passe il un problème non non on gère
c'est bon vous devez respecter le
surveillant comme on respecte un
enseignant est-ce que c'est clair pas
surveillant monsieur je suis le nouveau
professeur de
mathématique pour Pronote quelqu'un
pourra me montrer bien sûr je te montre
à la récréation si tu veux moi aussi je
peux te montrer la rrêtré tuux ou moi je
peux te montrer après ou avant l'AR
rêtré ils sont très lourds c'est normal
ok vous posez vos affaires par terre on
fait tout ensemble on s'en TR d'accord
to tu as toujours voulu être prof sur
tous mes bulletins il y avait écrit ne
fera jamais d'études longu mais
finalement je me débroui on ch les
équipes ça va mieux avec tes 4è il
m'épuise je les trouve même méchant par
moment
je peux savoir ce qui va pas mes cours
son chiants mes cours son plombés
s'emmerde et moi aussi je m'emmerde tu
crois que tu sais mais en fait tu sais
pas le pire c'est que tu sais même pas
que tu sais pas expliquer ce que tu sais
on distingue de grandes catégories de
volcan lesqu moi j'ai trouvé que votre
cours
était assez
[Musique]
ennuyeux si je suis prof c'est pour eu
je les vois évoluer je les vois
grandir hamburgers
moi j'ai fait médecine pour faire
plaisir à mon père j'ai échoué
i à ton âge j'avais arrêté mes études je
faisais du S
Fab toi tu as toujours eu la vocation
personne n là au début elle arrive quand
tu es balancé dans un collège et puis tu
découvres que tu es à ta
place alors vous vous êtes le prof de
français bah on l'a compris dans la B
annonce qui ennuie ses élèves autant que
lui-même la première question sur sur ce
personnage et sur la vocation aussi
comment garder la flamme vous vous êtes
interrogé là-dessus vous oui c'est
intéressant parce que comme toutes les
aventures de
vocation ce métier de prof ce métier de
ou cette aventure d'acteur
ou la médecine ou beaucoup d'ailleurs de
de métiers il suffit d'être passionné
pour le rendre
essentiel il y a une remise en question
mon personnage finalement au bout de de
35 ans d'exercice se rend compte que ses
élèves s'ennuient et lui aussi s'ennuie
donc c'est la preuve par 4atre que
finalement sa
période la bonne période est révolue
peut-être qu'il est dépassé moi j'aime
beaucoup cette analyse parce que
finalement ça prouve une véritable
intelligence se poser la question et
puis il y a une analogie avec ce métier
d'acteur pour moi est-ce qu'au bout de
ans je suis devenu dans la maîtrise ou
dans le savoir faire tout ce que j'ai
toujours détesté et la chance avec ce
film c'est que je me suis retrouvé avec
une génération dont je pourrais être le
père suite d'acteurs que j'admire que
j'ai toujours admiré depuis 5 ou 6 ans
où je les ai découverts qui sont des
acteurs avec des personnalités très
singulières très aigu très puissante que
ça soit William lebgil que ce soit
Vincent Lacoste Louis Bourgouin ou
encore magnifique Adel
exarchopouos sont des des des acteurs
qui qui n'ont bah qui qui qui ne sont
pas commun je dirais même mais que moi
moi je me trouvais assez commun à côté
d'eux euh et et donc la remise en
question c'est s fait de d'elle-même
c'estàd est-ce qu'on joue pareil et puis
finalement bah oui c'est pas qu'on est
les meilleurs mais on joue pas on vit
c'est aussi ça le succès d'intouchable
c'est d'avoir vécu cette amitié plutôt
que de la feindre vous savez cette
phrase magnifique de marivau j'ai déjà
dû vous le dire dans la dans la la
dernière fois mais j'adore cette phrase
les acteurs ceux qui font semblant de
faire semblant pour moi ça c'est
magnifique parce que si on est acteur
c'est pour vivre les situations c'est
pas pour les jouet les jouet c'est c'est
c'est c'est l'amateur alors qui joue qui
qui joue les trucs qui s'amuse et puis
quand il y a une scène d'émotion au lieu
de souffrir et ben il fait semblant de
souffrir parce qu'il a pas envie de se
faire mal alors qu'un interprète s'il a
une scène d'émotion il faut déjà qu'elle
passe par le plexus pour atteindre le
plexus du spectateur donc il faut déjà
qu'il souffre pour montrer son émotion
ça c'est pas donné à tout le monde euh
la notion de groupe elle est
fondamentale chez vous vous avez parlé
de l'attachement à un réalisateur un
mteur en scène la transmission aussi
c'est très prégnant dans votre histoire
dans votre trajectoire vous auriez pu
être prof non je crois pas parce que
j'ai pas de patience j'ai pas de
patience j'ai non non aucune patience ça
vous étonne pas et puis surtout je je je
je n'arrive pas à structurer ma pensée
non je je ne sarais pas je je je
malheureusement parce que vraiment j'ai
ce ce souci de transmettre parce que
c'est pas que j'ai inventé des choses ni
même que j'ai des secrets mais j'ai euh
j'ai compris j'enlève la prétention mais
j'ai j'ai j'ai compris ce pourquoi les
interprètes étaient fait c'est ultra
simple c'est pour être vivant tout le
reste ne marche pas il y a une phrase
pardon de
baudriard qui dit et c'est en
littérature mais qui dit il ne faut rien
signifier il faut laisser surgir et ça
ça me fait penser exactement à notre
métier Thomas Lilti parce que vous avez
tourné ensemble médecin de campagne en
2016 je voudrais qu'on envoie une image
aussi un extrait parce que il dit
beaucoup de vous en médecine interne il
le prendrait pour quelques jours hein je
connais bien le service ça permettrait
d'y voir plus clair en théorie oui mais
dans ce cas précis non pourquoi parce
qu'à chaque fois que je l'ai fait il est
revenu plus affaibli he il était moins
bien après qu'avant al fait le choix de
le maintenir à domicile et puis c'est ce
qu'il veut rester chez
lui alors on y croit et on assume
ouais enfin si fait une cpticémie une
embolie un trop du
rythme
non c'est sûr que ce serait plus simple
de l'envoyer à
l'ostour ce médecin de campagne ce rôle
du docteur Werner précisément qui ne vit
que pour son travail mais qui est obligé
de ralentir son activité car il est
atteint d'un d'un cancer je sais qu'il a
été très déterminant marquant en tout
cas pour vous ce rôle oui oui parce que
vous
savez les rôles de héros ne sont pas
très intéressants parce qu'ils n'ont
aucun
défaut malgré le succès de James Bond
pour un interprète James Bond est pas
tout à fait intéressant c'est beaucoup
plus intéressant de jouer un monstre
parce qu'ils sont plus complexes et puis
qu'ils ont des défauts en l'occurrence
et qu'il faut leur amener un tout petit
peu d'humité pour qu'il soit crédible et
dans James Bond il faudrait lui amener
un tout petit défaut il faudrait qu'il
soit radin faudrait qu'il soit pas
quelque chose non il y en a pas et là ce
rôle est un rôle de héros en ce sens que
ce médecin est avant tout un humaniste
et ça ça m'a permis euh ce que je veux
dire c'est que si vous voulez vous
pouvez pas toujours vous montrer
bifurquer les rôles pour vous montrer
beau vous voyez ce que je veux dire ça
c'était le cinéma d'hier c'est-à-dire
que le type jouait un type quelconque
bah non il en faisait un type
exceptionnel parce que comme ça le
public se disait ah formidable il
confondait le rôle avec le le type quoi
là ce type est très humain
alors ça m'a permis si vous voulez c une
chance ça m'a permis peut-être de de me
laisser aller complètement parce que moi
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance donc si
j'étais un monstre aujourd'hui c'est que
vraiment je serais un con et cette
chance que j'ai eu je me dois de la
rendre c'est comme un boomerang pour moi
si vous rendez pas votre chance elle
reviendra
euh vous avez refusé vous la Légion
d'honneur à l'on de ce rôle en quelque
sorte avec cet argument imparable et
frappé du bon sens j'ai envie de dire
c'est eux qui méritent oui bien sûr et
puis si vous voulez moi je me méfie des
distinctions pour les acteurs parce que
déjà qu'on est pas mal
narcissique tout à fait
égocentrique alors si en plus on nous
décore on finit en
lampadaire et en général russe quoi
c'est pas possible au même titre que
tout ce qui favorise l'ego me fait peur
parce que moi je veux rester
euh ça va être con ce que je veis dire
mais je je veux rester simple je
vourrais presque rester anonyme alors
que j'ai rêvé petit d'être célèbre
d'être un acteur célèbre c'est pour ça
que j'ai choisi cette carrière aussi si
j'avais fait que du théâtre je serais
pas devenu un acteur connu ou à peu près
donc moi toutes ces trucs là je m'en
méfie euh quand j'avais dit à mon père
on me propos la Légion d'Honneur je vais
la refuser il avait eu cette phrase de
commerçant que nous étions il dit mais
prends-la tu n'es pas obligé de le dire
c'est très jésuite et je dis NON NON
papa c'est c'est pour moi c'est pour moi
que je n'en veux pas au même titre que
je veux pas de chevalier des arzéettes
ensuite enlever tous les escrocs qui ont
une décoration vous allez voir qu'il il
reste pas grand monde chevalier des
arzellettes maintenant c'est donné au
vendeur d'assiette c'est donné aux
animateurs des missions d'aventure enfin
moi j'ai rien compte mais ça ne veut
plus rien dire du tout la mise au point
de François clusé vous pouvez embarquer
votre petit soda si vous voulez au
fauteuil vous cuisinez vous un peu quand
vous êtes dans les alpes maritimes ou
c'est votre épouse qui est en cuisine
c'estàdire qu'est-ce que vous voulez que
je vous dise ma femme est est une telle
cuisinière un cordon bleu voilà c'est ça
je sais que vous aimez pas attendre au
restaurant vous avez pu être agacé voir
vous lever ou pas non non non il fut un
temps je pouvais attendre des heures et
des heures parce que je buvais alors si
vous voulez j'arrivis au restaurant avec
des potes et j'avais déjà fini une
bouteille de rouge avant même passer la
commande euh ensuite on on buvait à
table pas mal il y avait toujours une
hisoire de digestif on profitait de la
vie on pensait que c'était comme ça
qu'on en profiterait mieux donc je
pouvais attendre mais maintenant que je
bois de la flotte attendre avant de
prendre la commande je l'accepte encore
parce que je suis pas le seul client
attendre entre les repas déjà ça ça
m'emmerde attendre pour avoir la note là
j'en peux plus vraiment donc je me lève
je vais payer au comptoir parce que mais
aussi pourquoi c'est parce que je vais
souvent au restaurant c'est pas une fête
vraiment pour moi et oui ça participe
aussi de ce métier d'acteur bien sûr euh
vous voulez bien si vous vous souvenez
qu'il y a une petite télécommande qui
fonctionne voilà vous voulez bien
actionner enfin appuyez sur le bouton
principal François
clusé ça ce que j'ai fait j'ai regarde
énormément de cartes postales aussi je
n'ai pas pris un acteur que je n'ai pas
vu sur une des cartes postales
c'est-à-dire que il fallait que vraiment
que par exemple euh Fran qucluset qui
joue le je le jeune homme euh qui lui je
crois qu'il était il n'était jamais allé
en Bretagne de sa vie mais c'est un de
ceux que je voyais le plus souvent sur
les cartes postales il était à tous les
mariages à tous les c'était une tête
vraiment caractéristique du coin alors
je l'ai je l'ai pris pour ça et
d'ailleurs je j'étais ravi parce que
c'est un acteur
étonnant bon ben là évidemment Chacha
chabol qui parle de vous Chacha et
d'ailleurs c'est drôle parce que vous
voyez aujourd'hui où il est parti je
tourne avec Lilti et vraiment il se il
ils se ressement tous les deux par leur
humanisme par leur générosité par le
fait que eux sont des leaders alors il y
a eu ce premier film ensemble qu'il
évoquait Cheval d'orgueil et puis vous
avez enchaîné avec un film très marquant
l'enfer votre premier grand rôle au côté
d'Emmanuel
Béard quel rôle a-t-il eu dans votre
existence dans votre trajectoire Claude
Chabrol oh bah d'abord comme vous le
disiez c'est le premier méant en scène
qui me donne un rôle très important et
je vois pendant des années des années on
on a pensé que le rôle que j'avais tenu
dans l'enfer faisait de moi un très bon
acteur donc il m'a donné un passeport
pour la suite beaucoup de mett en scène
m'ont engagé après avoir vu ce film donc
ça c'est une chance formidable et
humainement alors humainement c'est
c'est peut-être encore le plus important
important si vous voulez j'ai parce que
je n'avais pas dans ma famille la la
culture qu'il avait nous étions des
comment on dit des artisans commerçants
voyez on vendait des journaux mais donc
on n'ouvrait pas les livres et Chacha il
avait ça puis il avait beaucoup de cœur
un jour dans dans l'enfer justement il y
avait une scène je m'approche un peu de
la scène était terminée je m'approche un
peu de sa femme Aurore qui était sa
scripte et pour savoir comment elle en
elle qu'est-ce qu'elle en pensais et
elle elle me fait signe en montrant
Chacha Chabrol et en montrant qu' qu'
pleurait quoi et et
ça ça ça m'aimeux vraiment c'est une
grande chance grande
chance il y a eu comme ça des très
belles rencontres très fortes des très
beaux rôles
également j'aimerais bien qu'on aille
sur une autre expérience plus
tard vous voulez bien appuyer sur le
bouton pardon oui
zou d'ailleurs que deviens zou non c'est
quoi ça ah je sais pas tu es voyages à
Paris tu pars tout le
temps Maria c'est elle c'est
elle pourquoi pas mais parce que c'est
les femmes avec qui on peut coucher une
fois ou deux puis c'est
tout tu parles de ce que tu connais pas
en tu vas pas ta vie en l'air
pour une espè
c'est sal conna cette femme conis par
pas comme ça j'ai pas 10 ans ta morale
j'en ai rien à tu poses à quoi là
tu crois que ta petite vie c'est quoi le
modèle
universel tu vas être très
malheureux si je te dis que c'est la
seule chose de ma
vie qu'est-ce tuattends de moi que je te
dise vas-y que tu es dans la vie dans la
passion non parce que j'y crois pas une
seconde
alors là on est en 2002 c'est
l'adversaire de Nicole Garcia film
inspiré de cette histoire vraie celle de
Jean-Claude roment cet homme qui s'est
inventé une vie s'en F mensonge il
assassine son épouse et ses enfants
c'est Daniel otil qui incarne ce
personnage vous vous rêviez de tourner
avec Nicole garsille et avec Daniel
aussi je crois oui nicole est vraiment
la la plus grande directrice d'acteur
que que j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer
je me rappelle avant dans une scène
l'impression d'en faire très peu elle me
dit fais en moins j'étais très paumé
parce que je me suis dit merde qu'est-ce
que je peux gommer je fais la prise elle
revient elle me dit encore moins encore
moins qu'est-ce qu'il faut que je fasse
et ben à force de me demander de moins
en moins évidemment ça a videré
complètement les intentions
éventuellement que j'avais pour la scène
je me suis retrouvé mentalement
complètement à poil et puis les choses
sont sorti bah comme on disait tout à
l'heure peut-être elles ont surgi quoi
et sur Daniel c'est vraiment le grand
acteur qui a qui qui est qui qui a été
le leader de toute ma génération j'ai
énormément d'admiration pour lui il a il
il il a su euh d'abord vivre tous ses
rôles et
ensuite c'est le premier acteur qui m'a
fait comprendre que c'est le spectateur
qui joue c'est pas l'acteur l'acteur vit
et le spectateur joue il y a il y a des
concomitance entre vous et Daniel
hotteuil il y a une forme de
ressemblance il y a des choses communes
oui la taille oui ou ouais le le charme
une
personnalité euh il y a eu un moment où
vous avez douté vous quand peut-être
l'époque était moins favorable et où les
rôles principaux étaient davantage
proposés à Daniel huteuil par exemple
oui bien sûr parce que moi ça a mis très
très longtemps parce que finalement il y
a eu un truc très drôle si vous voulez
j'acceptais les films d'abord parce que
moi je je d'abord d'abord je voulais je
voulais faire mon métier de sur croi
comme je vous l'ai dit je voulais faire
du cinéma parce que je voulais être
connu cé un rêve de gosse et ensuite
j'ai compris un jour que j'accepis les
films que Daniel refusait et et et si
Daniel les refusé c'est bien parce qu'il
n'était pas les meilleurs scripts ou les
meilleurs mettant en scène donc je les
ai je les ai fait bon il y a pas que lui
qui l' refusé mais j'ai fait ces films
qui étaient refusés par des vudettes et
moi qui n'en était pas une j'ai fait
comme ça 50 films d'auteur qui n'ont
jamais marché et donc je suis devenu un
peu le chat noir de la production
c'est-à-dire ah clusem Cluset Cluset
Cluset Cluset il fait pas une entrée
machin truc ça devenait assez angoissant
quoi finalement je me suis merde mais ça
va me jouer un tour ce truc-là mais vous
avez douté au point à un moment de vous
dire euh on prend on taille la route ah
non non non non non non parce que
franchement je je vous savez je je euh
je suis de bonne foi et c'est peut-être
ma seule qualité je suis de bonne foi
avec moi-même et j'essaie de l'être avec
tous ceux à qui je dois le respect ou en
tout cas tous ceux qui ont mon
admiration mon amitié et je suis fait
fait pour ça et le reproche que je me
fais c'est de ne pas en avoir usé
suffisamment j'aurais pu s'il y avait
été moins feignant mais je suis un grand
feignant j'ai une spécialité j'adore
dormir donc si si d'ailleurs si j'ai le
moindre coup de blouse je vais me
coucher et comme j'en ai eu pas mal j'ai
passé pas mal de temps au plumard et
donc c'était ma manière à moi d'oublier
c'esti quand vous dormez bah vous ne
souffrez pas donc c'est vachement bien
et et je pense que si j'ai un c'est pour
ça que je suis très content de retourner
au théâtre bientôt c'est que j'aurais pu
comme certains le font comme Daniel l'a
fait mais aussi comme berléan le fait
c'està dire berléan il est tous les ans
au théâtre vous voyez il n'a pas alors
que moi j'étais finalement un tout petit
peu frustré de pas jouer parce que vous
êtes obligé si vous voulez faire une
carrière de refuser pas mal de trucs
parce que si vous faites tout là il y a
dedans pas mal de merde donc vous
refusez vous refusez donc vous finissez
par faire un film par an et qu'est-ce
que vous foutez pendant les 10 mois qui
restent rien du tout et et là je me suis
dit c'est très con j'aurais dû jouer au
théâtre plus pas le cinéma mais le
théâtre top top top là ça suffit
excusez-moi mais vous tisez voustiser ce
théâtre dites-moi plus je en supplie
François maintenant qu'on se connaît
bien ça fait à peu près 15 ans que n'ai
pas joué et je rêvais d'un grand texte
et et finalement un jour je
reçois un mail d'un type qui s'appelle
Emmanuel Noblet qui est un acteur de
grande qualité et à qui on avait demandé
de faire une adaptation d'un livre qui
s'appelle encore une journée divine et
il a fait ces adaptations et il m'a
envoyé une lettre en disant je l'ai
faite pour vous et donc si vous voulez
la jouer parce que j'espère que vous
attendez ce texte ou un texte comme
celui-ci depuis longtemps autrement je
je le monte pas je le ferai pas avec
quelqu'un d'autre ça m'a beaucoup touché
mais ce qui m'a touché c'est de lire le
texte et là je me suis rendu compte
qu'il y avait absolument peut-être 90 %
de ma passion en terme de de situation à
jouer il s'agit d'un
psychiatre qui est enfermé dans un dans
un asile et qui est un type qui dit que
tout va bien pour lui qui comprend pas
qu'est-ce qu'il fait là et pourquoi on
l'a enfermé et j'adore ce ce genre de
dingerie et pourquoi on l'a enfermé
c'est parce que il est quand même plus
ou moins responsable d'avoir tué son
frère mais pourquoi il ne veut pas
l'avouer mais pourquoi il est plus ou
moins
euh accusé d'avoir tuer son frère c'est
parce qu'il est fou amoureux de la femme
de son frère donc le mec est quand même
sérieusement allumé et ça vous savez
dans les personnages de dingue c'est un
peu ce que je disais tout à l'heure la
complexité est merveilleuse parce que ça
passe d'un sujet à l'autre en plus c'est
un mythomane moi qui l' été toute ma
famille l'était d'un mythoman qui pense
avoir écrit un bestcellerire qui dit un
bestcellerire qui s'appelle changer le
monde et je finirai par ça sa version à
lui pour changer le monde c'est aller au
bout de ce qu'on ressent c'est-à-dire il
explique que si votre patron n'est pas
gentil avec vous et bien il faut s'en
prendre à sa femme euh si ça ne suffit
pas alors faut s'en prendre voilà vous
voyez une espèce de
voilà assin bah bien sûr il y a une
matière commenurable et effectivement il
y a de quoi se régaler on ai a j'imagine
François Cluset en attendant ce
rendez-vous sur scène est-ce que vous
voulez bien faire quelques pas dans cet
appartement yes vousvez que je suis
bilingue
euh le miroir est à l'opposé euh si vous
faites encore quelques pas si vous
voulez bien y faire un petit stop oui je
vois je vois et me répondre comme ça
très rapidement à deux trois questions
par exemple qu'est-ce que allez
qu'est-ce qui est le plus charmant dans
les yeux de votre épouse chez François
Cluset ah j'aimerais bien le savoir oh
non non euh non je crois que en partie
elle aimait bien ma fantaisie elle
aimait bien que euh que je je me marque
que je prends pas vraiment les choses au
sérieux puis après elle a vu que Ben
j'étais pas si costaud que ça que
j'étais plutôt fragile je lui ai
expliquais que c'était dû à mon enfance
et à mon job parce que mon mon boulot
moi c'est d'être fragile hein si si si
j'étais si j'avais un état d'âme de
déménageur ou de camionneur bah j'aurais
je pourrais pas faire ce métier où on
brasse sans cesse des émotions ensuite
qu'est-ce qu'elle trouve de bien chez
moi bon non mais après vous savez elle
dit n'importe quoi elle me trouve beau
enfin tous ces trucs là mais je la
laisse dire je la laisse le croire je
vais vous installer à la bibliothèque
derrière vous demi-tour vers la gauche
vous l'avez vu hein bah oui parce que en
plus il est rare parce qu'il est
vraiment très ancien il faut nous faire
la traduction hein c'est un casque de
soudeur n'est-ce pas oui un masque un
masque de soudeur alors ça c'est une
chance j'ai découvert la soudure en
autodidacte comme pratiquement tout
parce que je je suis faignant et très
orgueilleux donc si vous voulez c'est la
suite de de l'école je je je je
n'accepte pas qu'on m'apprenne quelque
chose c'est c'est et con et orgueilleux
donc je découvre les choses tout seul
alors c'est bien pour la littérature
j'ai pas besoin qu'on me lise les pages
mais la sculpture et plus exactement la
soudure c'était génial parce que j'ai
acheté un jour au BHV un truc acétylè
oxygène de bonbones acétylène oxygène
j'ai branché le truc j'ai ouvert je me
suis dit ça va me péter à la gueule et
puis finalement avec un briquet j'ai
foutu le le truc sur la buse et sorti
une une flamme comme ça et puis j'ai
regardé sur le mode d'emploi j'ai essayé
de de régler la flamme puis après j'ai
pris deux bouts de fer puis j'ai essayé
de les souder et tout ça puis là ça m'a
éclaté quand j'ai vu que ça tenait
j'étais trop content alors je commencé à
faire des trucs comme ça et qu'est-ce
que vous faites alors François je vais
pas vous mentir on a pensé à quelque
chose pour vous qui est lié si vous
faites quelques pas en arrière dans le
canapé il y a un cadeau pour vous dans
un paquet ah là ouais c'est évidemment
en rapport direct je vous en
prie
what encore bilingue vousvez remarqué s
ACC en plus magnifique alors ça c'est
magnifique parce
que ah non mais c'est beau vous pouvez
pas me faire plus plaisir ah parce qu'
alors vous voyez c'est un tablier mais
un tablier avec lequel évidemment on
peut pas se brûler parce que c'est une
espèce de DA très puissant euh et et
inenflammable
je suis trop content vous voulez bien
nous accompagner pour conclure d'une
musique elles sont à droite ces
propositions de 33 tours
euh voilà Serge ginbourg auti raing
téléphone Francis Cabrel Billy Olid les
Beatles tout ça vous accompagne depuis
des années
ouais là tout de suite vous avez envie
de quoi bah là vous voyez je sors
téléphone en plus le disque est sublime
alors voilà c'est effectivement le
disque s'écoute autant qu'il se
regarde je suis
content les quelques marches je monte
alors pas celle-ci les marches qui sont
derrière vous exactement et ça s'appelle
un métier sérieux qui vient de sortir
dans les salles
film de
Thomas on vous y retrouve avec
adelarcopulos avec bu lers avec Vincent
Lacoste bien sûr courisy merci beaucoup
François cl d'être venu nous
voir moi aussi à tout de suite de
l'autre côté de la
porte tring ouais
magnifique sal sal
voilà